okay all right uh so here's the deal uh
you may be wondering hey is the corridor
cast has it just become a thing where
where jake sam jordan and nick sit
around and play spyfall no it hasn't but
we're back for round two because we had
a great time last time we got a bunch of
people in the comments saying that we
should do it again we also got some
people telling us don't ever do this
again but you know what we're doing it
again so we're gonna play spyfall i hope
you enjoy the game i hope you're here
for the game the quarter cast will not
always be a game but we may play games
on the corridor cast so welcome back and
uh we've got obscure uh abstract and
different locations this time and we're
gonna give audio cues uh to all you
audio listeners about which location
we're at
uh before the round starts
don't worry we're saving up all of our
dank hot takes for our next podcast
they're gonna be double as dank and
doubles
you guys are gonna get some great
opinions we're all way better at this
game now too so it's gonna be a much
better listening experience and also a
friendly listener reached out to us on
twitter and said hey that's right yeah
we have a way better spyfall game that's
specially tailored
to you your play style
not like corridor locations or whatever
but it's on devious dot games they
actually have a bunch of other really
good online games shout out to jeff jeff
way
that's the guy who reached out to me
show us the way jeff
show me jeff
thank
i'm gonna like it on on this cast here
you go boom all right
so
yeah
let's let's get this started let's let's
just let's just jump into it let's just
jump right in
all right just if you have never played
spyfall there's one person who's a spy
who does not know the location everyone
else is in a location and they are
trying to verify who is and who is not
the spy through a series of questions
while the spy is trying to figure out
what the location is exactly so for our
first round we're starting with
base spyfall locations and they will get
progressively crazier
this is just casual regular logo okay
nick you're lieutenant dan
that yes
are we at the are we at the military
base lieutenant dan
that's for you to find out for you to
find out nice
for future games i'm gonna put the timer
up a little bit it's defaulting to six
minutes but whatever here we go
this round's location is the day
spa elty dan
all right you're right i'm starting it
off
all right sam
hey
do you think you'd have an easier time
convincing your mother or father to come
to this location
an easier time
that's a good question dude
it's so it's it's really hard to discern
the the answer to what the location is
with that question sorry
just had to say
my parents they're kind of sticklers
i don't think i'd be able to convince
them to come here
they peculiar tastes either of them
either of them
well i'm sorry okay i'm thinking about
this through my page you shouldn't have
asked the follow-up question
no more questions
okay all right all right
jordan
would you say this is
the type of place
you walk away with a great experience
absolutely
oh
every time sorry that's a follow-up
question don't answer that
yeah he's gonna have a follow-up you're
not allowed
if it's like the casino it's like i
don't maybe you had a good time maybe
you didn't i do you not know the
location
i mean i know the location oh okay okay
good yeah
very good i'm just wondering if you guys
know it oh yeah
everyone here does my answer
okay well why don't you ask the
questions jordan oh yes um yeah i forgot
um
[Music]
jake
yes
stones
or
water stones or water
did you you just asked me stone did i
hear that right stones or water uh-huh
okay
um
don't do the sarcastic answer
and if you do wink really obviously i i
think i think both
okay yeah yeah cool that's that's the
way that i i'm not i'm not mad at that
at all okay
um
but uh
uh nick um
yes but uh
for me it's stones
and water
um but but for you
it is it uh
guy that's too obvious i can't ask that
i can't ask that
his breaking point
okay um
for the record it's stones that's my
little bonus answer
for the record do you think do you think
that um
uh there's
these are often found on military bases
oh
[Applause]
jake i i think you'd be hard-pressed to
find
this location on a military base
okay
all right i'm satisfied with that answer
he's a lieutenant
i know that's why i asked yeah because
yeah i make the rules he makes all the
rules i mean he makes all the rules for
the corporals and the privates
and the sergeants
for that matter
not so much all the rules
sam yes
cucumbers
carrots or bell peppers
hmm
sounds
delicious i'm gonna go with
cucumbers okay
oh wow
uh oh
i think the problem is that the spy
knows the location i think that's the
problem here yes spy already knows
absolutely jake i 100 agree with you
well everyone's answering these really
well unless it's nick of course who's
given the most ambiguous answers mm-hmm
um
lieutenant dan
you just said sam answered well to a
question which i posed the question to
which means that i would have
asked it well yes which means gosh dang
it yeah
but i could also be the spotlight yeah
except for that might be online but then
nick could be the spy that also knows
the location
yes to figure out we're stuck between a
stone and a hard place
[Laughter]
all right
this is
this is gonna be
well no it's that one
it won't be too obvious okay um
would you i'm gonna go with three shapes
all right
okay i like the i like the select choice
you know select
the multiple choice a class right
i hope this makes sense me too
are we talking
triangles
rectangles
or ovals
i'm gonna go with a rectangle
yeah i'm feeling rectangular here
okay
is it could it could it be that this
person maybe didn't put a spy option on
this game
that's something a spy would say oh
maybe there is a spies maybe there's no
spot okay well the time's up the time's
up so i feel like you got to ask one
more question well yeah let's let's we
can do an extra minute this was a little
shorter if you
okay i'm feeling it too i feel like
we could usually it's an eight-minute
game
yeah
also yeah i guess it's in your court
yeah ask away final question it's up to
you nick yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
what would you wear what would you wear
what would you wear when you go here
what that's such a specific that's so
specific i would
i would wear my normal clothes why
why would i have any other
you know choice
[Applause]
but it's still the way he answered it
it's
i don't know but think about it
his question to sam
was
was good and sam i think sam is the spy
because he's had the most ambiguous
questions it's the cathedral
oh he's wrong
i was about to raise my hand if you
would raise your hand against sam yeah
because of sam's first answer to the
questions yeah it was the first thing
that sam said i was like um what sam
it's it is the day spot it's a spa a
dyspo
why did you choose cucumbers because i
said i don't know what
right well sam has sam really likes
those multiple choice questions
and you know i think because it benefits
him as both a spy and a non-spy but
this one was just a little that's i
don't know tough
all right more choices next time because
you know a third chance of getting it
right that's too high let's get weird
with the locations let's get weird with
the logo so there's some wacky like
super obscure historical locations right
as part of this oh time travel very cool
yes you want to level up the spyfall 2
locations
so yes
similar i'm also adding two more minutes
to our clock nice here we go
so we have new locations art museums
baseball stadiums candy factories cat
shows cemeteries coal mines construction
sites gas stations harbor docks jail
jazz club library race track retirement
home rock concert sightseeing bus subway
the united nations
and a wedding
not as many locations
this round's location is the jazz club
mine do
all right yeah
and here
we
go
round two i'm first
who do i start with nick yes for
betraying me in the last
game
uh are you good
[Laughter]
i set you up nicely
come on all right question away sam
[Music]
all right
history check
ancient civilization
best
defines
this location
what ancient civilization bestest
ancient china
okay
sure
wait is this a multiple choice question
ancient
india or ancient greece
i would have to say ancient greece all
right
i like your confidence
carry on all right
i don't know man
nick let's go let's go
alright jake
okay
what
hm
let's hear it
i can't be too obvious
hmm
this is
come on guys we need we need questions
okay we've already wasted two minutes
only one i'm gonna go back to one of my
favorites i'm gonna go back here i have
one hour to do that one of my favorites
jake
okay
if you were to do one kind of exercise
in this location all right would it be a
running laps
or c i'd rather not do any exercise in
this location
well for me
i mean i mean and i mean
me you know
i do
a lot of exercise at this location
but it's not what people
consider to be
traditional exercise okay
it's
it's a lot of
fantastic answer your name
is cleared
not a spy
all right
good
good good
all right um
see that's my new spy game by the way
i'm just telling you i'm gonna really
like amp up people after they give an
answer whether it's right or wrong it's
like like right now it's already here i
can't be the spy great answer joy
everyone great answer yes
do you do you have to pay money
to enter this location
well
i'll tell you this
sometimes
sometimes not
because sometimes there's
other things you spend money
on
while there
as to why you don't have to
initially that is true
there are other things
like a candy factory
i answered my question jake
okay
whoa wait did was that an official guess
was that your official special
[Applause]
so how many minutes do you have to leave
up for jake yeah
it's like it's like a like a like a like
a free cat show and you
come home with a cat
totally
listen
totally you know that wasn't you know
that wasn't me
yeah just play it
off just write it out i would have a lot
more
style you know yeah yeah
wait till the next one personal a lot
more personal improvisational style if i
was to say
yeah you know you know you'd be like
yeah okay okay your honor i would like
to make you're honored
okay
your honor yo let me tell you something
now okay all right
who's asking the questions
me
all right
[Music]
i dare you
sam yes
bam
i would say
like brighter lights or like dim lights
[Laughter]
fair enough well fair enough
we all know the
answer to this question
it is very obvious let me
browse the other location so that when i
deliver the correct answer it's not too
obvious
ah yes please
um
well
kind of gives it away but you know what
ah man see last time i did the sarcastic
answer and the wink didn't save me so
you know what i don't care dim lights
okay cool
sorry
so by the way since that was the correct
answer
if you feel confident to vote for a spy
by now
let's do it
time's running out
all right i do i do feel confident to
vote for a spy sam okay nick yeah you
have one more let me get more specific
we talked about ancient civilizations in
our last discussion
you answered
i think correctly it was an ambiguous
question yes so do i let's uh talk
again okay um
you know i love ancient history sam so
um
all right
uh it's a simple multiple choice one all
right here we go i love it
sam's multiple we're talking about
here we go are we talking about string
yarn
or thread
interesting
classic
thread
sounds good time to vote
[Laughter]
of what everything we've said
what was it
the answer to that question was
definitely string
what was it because because it was the
same
i don't get the string strings like
bass
man all i can think of was a piece of
yarn
i was thinking thread because i thought
it was like some like you know tableau's
or something are you just like listening
in
he's like i heard the whole thing okay
are you are you doing the double bone
phones is that no for some reason mine
were she that goes charge me
oh dang i was so i was you know i
thought jake was saying he exercises his
mind and cultural muscles um
and the dim lights you know i assumed
and jordan's saying you know you can pay
for stuff while you're there i thought
it was a gift shop and you know
something exactly for you you don't have
to pay to walk into exactly that was my
some jazz clubs are free and their
museums are definitely low light yeah
do you drink light was like that one
thing that like confirmed my my bias i
know i was like it's either art museum
jazz club
that's about it
man
that's the threat me away dude i frickin
i banked on tapestries never bank on
tapestries listen
tapestry
okay
never
all right let's do some let's do some
historical
settings here this is going to get crazy
all right this is now now we're getting
crazy
it's time it's time
it's time for travel
time travel
it's time for time travel we can be
anywhere in time step into my time
machine
oh yes where look at these locations we
have places such as a cannibal tribe in
the 1500s
a lunar base in 2035
the great that's right now that's in
like 14 years i appreciate that they
give sorry okay how about try
apocalyptic wasteland in 2085.
okay there this is gonna be really silly
here we go 1180 bc
everyone look at this
wild location oh my god i'm trying to
take it all in yet old west saloon in
1885.
the black plague
2049 there's a neanderthal
have taken over
i like the black plague it just doesn't
give an actual like location it's just
like the black plague you know ever
dying all of all of western europe it's
like the 2020 of like freaking
ninja academy 1450. there's some great i
love berlin 1945 hitler's last stand
all right the first olympic games 177 70
776 the first olympics 1776
when george washington
threw the first shot
this is so [ __ ] good
come on jordan we got questions oh i
have the first question so let me see
yeah it's they're not connecting very
well uh i had i had to connect to mine
manually i just had to keep guessing the
question one first like if you may have
connected to it in the past so yeah but
it says connected and then it said
battery high on here but it's not
all right maybe you have to switch it
over still you have to switch your audio
setting over
let me ask a vase let me ask nick
a very basic uh starter question oh
we're starting okay don't worry
we'll repeat these uh
is this is this location in ad
[Laughter]
that's cheap
that's cheap nick how you feeling right
now
oh you feel like that was a close call
and you almost got it wrong
who wants to vote
let's just kick him out
all
okay don't ask that one again that's a
game manager that's amazing okay
right
dude i was so amped for this round i was
just going to say
all the questions
i was just going to poop
[Laughter]
i just ended that round in a single
question yeah that's brutal all right
yeah that was a lunar base in 2025 leave
now because i don't have to be the spot
all right try it again next next game
all right here we and here
we go
and i'm asking the first question what's
our um password again
nine b y
x b
why x b
it's the battle of berlin in 1945 this
round's location is the french
revolution
all right i'm asking the first question
all right
jordan
what
do you say we do with them
what should we do with them
all of them
yeah
we're fired up
what are we going to do to them
well
what whale
um
i'm
just a newcomer
i'm just a newcomer here and i don't
have really a voice
that's true that's why we're fired up
here
okay
ah
all right
interesting yeah that is very bad
interesting
it makes me wonder what your character
is but we'll talk about that later yeah
we'll get into that after the game ends
yeah
uh so we
jordan take it off take it away
hey yeah
i suck in history guys just to let you
know um
so i'm not gonna ask nick
[Music]
what um do you think you're like wearing
me
yeah um
i'm for sure
so definitely
i love wearing black
okay
all right
yeah yeah that's uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i can't ask you so let me direct my
questioning to jake here
yes
please um
what do we do with them what are we
doing yeah what do we do
beep
um
do you think around these parts
we uh we view the the government with a
favorable eye or
is it quite the opposite
yeah
do you mean the government
no it's just just around these parts
jake
around these parts well i mean
obviously it depends on who you ask nick
you know i mean and and government what
what is it exactly you know i mean
because there's there's some have some
ideas and then others a lot of others
some have some very particular ideas
some
very very few some and that's all right
i'm satisfied thank you okay
you're welcome
you're satisfied all
right
perhaps i didn't get it but
all right whatever yeah yeah perhaps you
didn't
perhaps you didn't sam maybe maybe you
should have a question yes as if i was
the spy saying i don't get it like i
don't get the question or the answer it
doesn't mean i don't know the location
okay
try me
is this this is a tough one to not give
away because there's been a lot of
information divulged
already how's there
yes
um
here do the activities at this location
are they known in history to happen
during the day or at night
at day or night yeah day or night
um
honestly i don't know the correct answer
to this one but i could fire back an
answer
you could fire back an answer that would
reveal to me that you know the location
without knowing the answer to mike
during this time period i'm just saying
during this time period the activities
that they did there you've done
you've done some of these activities
actually
and nick i believe
you too
you have done these activities
as well
this guy
yeah right i'm satisfied with that yeah
unless could be right i could be right
i'm definitely right i'm a hundred
percent right and if you don't believe
me
then you're a spy
wait wait wait wait wait wait
are you being sarcastic sam right now no
i'm not being sarcastic in fact with an
eyesight
is living proof that you have done those
activities you too nick hmm
i uh
yeah i can't deny it i can't deny it
okay
sam ask ask one more question and then i
i think nick i think we can vet this yes
what were you wearing on the day
that you used
a historical instrument from this time
period
oh man well
like an old west saloon yeah you know
that's not the location i'm just
generally
it was a situation where i didn't really
want to show my face
so i was wearing
well
you could call it a hood i guess
okay
well i was trying to get a little more
specific than that with like what you
were literally wearing because i
remember it
and you weren't wearing a hoodie no with
what with what not not nick's camera oh
you mean
in your fantasy of when i actually did
this in my in my fantasy in which you
actually used a historical instrument
from this time period so it would have
been a a white coat
so but you already said you you already
said you wear black i know but well
there's two different realities
unfortunately i have to vote for jordan
i have to second that
third
[Music]
wait a minute
wait none of us are the spiders
sam
no no i'm not despite it what have you
done it's nick
it's nick it's it's not i
is it you it's not you jake
it's you well unless i am and of course
it's the french revolution and off with
all your heads because i totally am the
spy and that is definitely the location
it's not there definitely it is not the
french revolution yeah you got it you
did it it's jake
hell yeah good job everyone's gonna
so
what tipped you off jake i'm curious
well there is two so there's two things
he doing goddess he doesn't know us he
doesn't got you
got you good
first of all jordan started sounding
like she wanted to start with a with a
french accent
and and i was like
is that a french but then it sounded
like she changed it because she didn't
want to give it away as a french accent
and then i was like okay we're either in
the speakeasy
or it's the french revolution or it's
like it's some sort of social event
like there's a lot of people
and then nick you were like
black clothing and so i was like oh
maybe it's the black plague
but then uh
the guillotine thing really yeah that
really kind of
brought it home
oh shoot would you when you were like
when you were like
you've done this i was like
[Laughter]
darn it
well
it's still fun
no jake your your answer to my question
was nice and vague it was so vague that
i thought it was not vague
yeah
that's why i decided i was openly like i
don't get what's going on
well no i mean because you know they're
yeah never mind
the royalty
the reason why i thought it was you
jordan was because jake was answering so
i mean he caught on pretty quick but you
also did like a southern accent so i was
like oh she's just like
i don't know how it turned southern it
got southern new and i was like i was
like oh i was like uh definitely jordan
i'm gonna work on that 80 or bc right
boy
oh boy let's go that was a good one that
was good this is funny all right shall
we yeah we shall
oh hey there it's it's me again here to
tell you about today's sponsor story box
you see i've been doing some extensive
research i've been reading through all
the books that you see behind me and i
gotta say none of these books provide a
complete stock solution for all of your
stock asset needs like storybox.com you
definitely don't have to read a book to
understand that storyblocks provides
high quality 4k b-roll images audio
assets motion graphics and after effects
templates and more for example i was
reading through this plumbing heating
and air conditioning book here no part
of this book told me that storyblocks
offers an unlimited all-access plan to
use in whatever types of projects you
want that's right whether you're
monetizing them whether they're for a
client whether they're for your own
personal endeavors anything you download
with that unlimited all access plan you
can use because it's all royalty free
none of these books said anything about
that and it's a real shame we use
storybox all the time here at corridor
digital because we don't have to spend
time reading through books or going out
and collecting b-roll or audio or images
or assets on our own all we have to do
is go on their site look through their
virtually unlimited library download
whatever we need and use it and move on
with our day i'll tell you what i'll
make you a deal okay you head on over to
storybox.comcast to get started and i'll
read through the rest of these and i'll
report back to you in about two to three
weeks and let you know if i found
anything different i better get started
and uh you better get started on that
url click the link in the description
below now back to the podcast all right
see you later
this round's location is the battle of
waterloo
all right
jordan flex that history muscle
i don't know much about this myself
[Laughter]
but
uh yeah i guess
we'll find out what happens
this is my favorite history
if i'd pick one of my favorite moments
from history
this is the top moment
this is in the top one
this is the 20 moments in the top 20
seconds that's ever passed
water or land jake
unless you don't know the location
that's a very good question
because i can't answer it
i literally i cannot answer that
question
you ask me water or land
i cannot answer that question
why well is that allowed so should she
does she get a second one
let me answer the question okay let me
let me answer the question
it is literally
impossible
for me to answer that question okay
i can take that i can i gotta use that
answer next time
no like okay if i answer that one
okay cool i'm not convinced by that okay
anyway
good i didn't think he would be nick
so uh i'll be here all right actually
why don't i ask you a question nick yeah
why don't you
okay well um
oh
you know how
in the french revolution do you remember
that how they said
off with their heads right mm-hmm
well
in this
one in this historical event
it was more like
off
with
oh i can't i can't answer this i can't i
can't ask this question okay don't give
it away
that you're a spy
the the rothschild banking family may or
may not have had a very significant
event
as a result of this event
this is a this is this is a little bit
conspiracy but it's also
i don't know
because i hear
look i've heard a lot of conspiracies
that have the name ross child banking
family
and a lot of them are batshit insane so
yeah i'm gonna say maybe
but this is where it all starts for them
yeah and you know
it's definitely not the ninja academy in
the future
[Laughter]
in the future it hasn't begun yet
oh [ __ ]
all right i'm sorry i i listen i'm sorry
those were both terrible questions
it's all right i'm sorry
um
oh
jordan hi um
let's see here let's see here wait you
should ask sam a question
look at look at how shady he's looking
over
there that's just sam though
there's a traitor amongst our time
sphere
you know
you can trust me i'm here to correct the
timeline
yeah no i'm just trying to think of
something that
like
if you are
oh yeah you know this you'll know the
reference of oh i think that's
are you asking sam or me the question
who did you choose it's me i'm in the
hot seat now okay
we're still here podcast listeners
yeah yeah sorry
this is a hard one crank up vault crank
the hardware here
you're getting my brain working
you can hear his brain work you can hear
his brain working he's trying to get out
of question
that's
especially when it's a neanderthal cave
from 200 000 years ago
do you think uh
okay if you had to describe this
location in history by one of these
phrases okay
a
a david and goliath story
the best comeback in history
or c
red versus blue
oh
wait which one would you choose ooh
wow you are honing in you are like you
are getting them sensors calibrated
you are getting there
before i answer that question let me
just
browse my location list to make sure
that when i deliver the correct answer
some of them are vague it doesn't reveal
should i
non-spies should i just say the right
answer
i mean
you know what i'm not going to say the
correct answer
because there's a chance there's a spy
here uh-huh that sounds like a cop-out
that a spy would say yeah don't say the
answer just
ask a question there's nothing in this
that's gonna immediately give it away
well one answer points to a specific
nation uh-huh just answer the questions
just answer the question
answer how are you
versus blue
oh here we go
that's interesting
no
all right ask a question let's go wait
come on yeah okay oh oh oh okay the
timer's paused by the way let me just
say here we go that's not the answer i
was looking for i know and i just
realized that
this event took place somewhere else
i looked at the date i'm like
so you think wrong here okay cool um so
um
jordan i think your first question
if if you're not a spy your first
question kind of cleared your name
pretty quickly
i'm a little concerned that one of these
two is the spy over here
just well it's not why did nonstop
all right nick yeah i can't fire back at
you jake oh man
hey all right bring it on bring it on
okay
um you gonna go classic multiple choice
no yeah i'm just no a b a b okay all
right
a d or b c are we gonna
are we gonna walk too far
or are we gonna walk too short
definitely too short bumping too short
in the super sport
okay what i'm saying
yeah
okay
i'm a little concerned about nick over
here who is it
he's shredded with history yeah jordan
let me just ask you a question but his
what do you think about jake's let's
let's pause the clock here nick
let's review jake's answers questions
what do you think about
them breaking i like being questioned by
someone i'm i'm actually suspecting of
being a spy right because i don't want
to give you more more insight into it
i'll tell you how what i think about
them
he has a degree of confidence and in
what seems to be some sort of insider
knowledge of this event
that's going above my
non-buff history head
so
i think he
said the correct answer
what about his question it's what a
conspiracy theory question what do you
think of that
sam we all know it's you man no it's not
me you're going to be
that question
allow me to ask allow me to ask it's
between two people jordan so that i
can't yeah that's not her so that we can
let's allow it let's let's do that let's
do it let's allow it let's lock it down
let's lock
this team down
there are a couple people that i see
yes jake
are you familiar with a man who goes by
the name the duke of wellington
tis me
it's you that's what my role says
that's what your role says
i'm really sorry i [ __ ]
jacked that [ __ ] up i should have let
you answer i'm shall i still answer
jordan
do you want to give me another question
i will are you familiar with the land of
belgium
oh just a wee bit yeah
okay
i mean it makes sense
[Music]
i'm
i'm i'm
never gonna do this with you guys again
out of just like embarrassment
you guys chose these places all right
jordan you hit us with a banger
hit us with a banger and let's vote
frankly
i'm ready to eat sam even if it's not
you i'm ready to vote you out just on
just on that faux pas you just went
through
uh
sam was this a beautiful looking
uh experience
i pleasing might i say i think
this was not a beautiful experience
and kind of gross
[Laughter]
it's kind of gross it's kind of gross
okay cool
either sam or jordan no you know i
jordan's first question really makes me
think she's not a spy and now i'm
thinking which one you guys caught on
okay so
here's the thing
nick i'm coming at you hard one final
question okay one final question okay
let's go
is this
location
made famous
by film
music
or comic books
as of recently
film
but in its day
music
very interesting i have a bad feeling
a very
deep burning bad feeling that there's no
spy here
[Laughter]
i said that on the first round you know
how is there no spy
there's a spy
at least one of you two okay i'm gonna
vote for sam okay
fine vote for me i don't care i'm not it
wait it's really not you
no
maybe
who else is voting for sam anybody else
jordan yes nick i can't see your hand
you see jake's knowledge of history
makes me think he could have caught on
or is sam just pretending he's not
actually history but did we actually
have a round where there wasn't a spy no
we didn't no we have there's no
president for that okay
okay so then okay sorry i got confused
well i'm not the spy
so i don't know who to vote for
[Laughter]
well why don't you propose a vote i need
guys the game is over we've been in this
game all right longer than eight minutes
we gotta vote
based on your your weird rothschild
question it listen i know it's like
it's a weird question i had a roommate
who we used to call crazy mike and he
was a conspiracy theorist and the first
time i got into the history of this
event it was let's hope for jacob yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
none of this
and no don't vote for me because it's
not me
i'm just a humble calvary man okay
at this location okay nick i don't care
i'll just keep
nick i'm voting for sam
caught on okay you voted for me
yeah guess what
not the spy aye
and it's definitely jordan
no it's it's not me is it jake again
survivor island right now who's the spy
well i propose a vote i propose this oh
it's jordan
yeah
i was at a hot air balloon
it was jordan
it's the battle of waterloo
damn
i saw that through the lens of you
prefacing this with like oh look i'm not
i don't know a lot of the history stuff
that we're dealing with so i was like oh
that's just like she's literally just
taking the
word waterloo
and going like oh we underestimated and
that's why jake was probably i mean
that's a perfect question too because
it's like it could still be anything
yeah i thought i had it
i thought i had it but you did that's
the thing like that was the perfect
question because it threw all of us off
and then immediately
and then i come in and steal beef
wellington dude
yeah
damn
dude that was those were some amazing
questions though um
gosh darn it
napoleon fought that yeah yeah yeah it
was thinking about russia where they
like overextend themselves that's my
question
they went too far into russia well well
i i thought you were making a short joke
because he was a short guy so i thought
you were like for sure
yeah and i thought a hot air balloon if
you walk too far you fall off
yes so you gotta just show some distance
did you just decide hot air balloon and
you're just like i'm gonna go with it
i'm just gonna set up questions i was
like this is definitely hot air that's a
great because jake wouldn't tell me if
it was land
and that hot air balloon isn't on
neither but what about this rothschild
thing
i'm not genuinely curious let's say that
for the next podcast
no no we gotta hit that according to
conspiracy theories abound uh there was
a man by the name of uh nathan amchel
ross child i believe
and he knew the outcome of of the battle
of waterloo before it hit the banks of
london and so he made a bunch of
basically bets
uh against people who did not know the
outcome and then when the outcome was
found obviously he made a bunch of money
he basically shorted
the information
are there like conspiracy theories that
he like dampened all the cartridges of
the french like he like
went in there so they couldn't fire
their muskets and then lost or something
carried off i didn't care to dig much
teeth i'll play uh then that um i just
that's all i know that's it's uh
huh interesting
that's a good one yeah well it's not
that much that doesn't seem too
conspiracy theories it's plausible the
the conspiracy theories on the ross
child family go deep into darkness over
the internet where weird people really
died
and so some of it's true and most of
it's not
but anyways let's let's do one more this
time travel thing's kind of fun it's
pretty hilarious
i am
dude that first question threw me off so
hard i was like
that is exactly the question i would ask
if i didn't know what the [ __ ] waterloo
was dude i'd be like
i got confused with like a revolutionary
war battle at the first at the beginning
and then i was like oh because red
versus blue yeah yeah i know
well it technically kind of was so that
that does apply i know but i checked
that's when i checked the year i was
like wait a second
um cool so
next round begins
this round's location is the black
plague
jordan
you get to
kick us off
all right cannibal tribe
1505 a.d let's go apocalyptic wasteland
let's go
hmm
[Music]
another classic jordan character let's
do it yeah this is your best strategy
if i were here
wait let her perform better speak let
her speak let her speak
it's a performance
yes
what is it
i'm just cracking adios
you have to pick one color
please please pick one color
just one to describe this situation at
hand
i would maybe it would be a very dark
color oh okay
very
so very dark
is this stonehenge where are we
i'm just going to keep it going
[Laughter]
nick
yeah would you
choose
between a hammer
or sickle
[Laughter]
i i
well i suppose
i would
choose
i would choose a hammer to rebuild
after these
these times we live in they rebuild
after these times
[Laughter]
can probably tell
not the lunar base
oh oh oh hold on
all
my right
oh [ __ ]
houston we have landing
here let me i'll keep it going
[Laughter]
jake
yes
would i say
this be a crisis of the young
or a crisis
of the
hour what say you
the crisis
the crisis is of the old
the crisis is of the old and
also of the young
okay it's the black plague
[Laughter]
are you the same
obvious it was so obvious i know i just
wanted to let you get your answer off
yeah yeah you know i just wanted to let
you do your medieval voice yeah just so
we complete the circle and then i was
like all right now we gotta we're gonna
from the first question you're like as
soon as i started the voice
get these fries off me all right all
right that was a speed round good job
sam
for more of these like beep boop ones
what's the beat boop start let's see if
you
where we improv like that that's that
was funny
this round's location
is a cannibal tribe in 1505.
okay oh
goodness all right
all right i'm first
all right
[Music]
more voices
before i get too hard on the rpg here i
just got to scan my locations
all right set
here we go hmm
would you say
that we must teach
these people christianity
jordan
jordan should we teach
christianity yeah oh yeah
on this hot air balloon
no not that one
down from this hot air balloon shall we
come down on this hot air balloon
and give them christianity
hi
ah i
all right i think
[Laughter]
i
i think
that
we are too far gone too far gone from
that okay
too far gone fair enough
all right
yes uh
of course
i mean of course
jake
no sorry it wasn't an actual guess i was
just making a joke oh [ __ ]
see you
what's going on
should we continue
[Laughter]
come on jordan
no we shouldn't because it's the spanish
inquisition
is your spy yeah you think it's a
spanish inquisition
you were right the first time i was you
know
she reacted like you said the location
oh my
[Laughter]
yeah that's
because you said should we teach them
christianity yes i was a priest in this
cannibal tribe thing i assumed i just
went to the only spanish thing
christian thing which was all about that
and then
jordan did like this
jacob
she was like a jiggle and it sounded
very spanish to me so i'm like all right
it's a spanish inquisition that's funny
i went through five accents trying to
find it
i should have gone with the opposite of
what i thought
it was like this i was a child in the
cannibal tribe you should i know i saw
you were already gearing up to like be
like like a crazy well i thought you
just
said i was like getting so amped for
jake to be the barrel trap oh my god
that is that is amazing
okay can we do one more
last one
last one keep it together people this
round's location
is the ninja academy
oh dude it's hard it's really hard
that's funny
all right
and here we go
oh i'm again the first
all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
jake
[Music]
okay um we doing characters again i
don't know i don't know if i'm gonna do
the character for this one
i don't think
jake
um
[Music]
okay so we got a location in front of us
here
okay some of us do yes what's a location
that's neces
i'm going to name a thing that's
going to be crucial to the operation
of this environment
all right
you're going to deliver the right answer
do you
for this to work
for this location to function
do we need rechargeable battery cells
do we need
an iron forge
or do we need
some great stone cutters
the key
to success
in this location
hey
is inside where there is
an iron forge
okay
cool
hell yeah brother
nailed it
in character
and correct answer
jordan
yes
does the mountain move
when the wind blows upon it
maybe sometimes
if you
think
and meditate on it
it possibly could
yeah
or blow really hard
cool
yes
yes um
i don't know why i always forget that
it's probably because i'm so within
myself um
nick should i
should i be worried about
jumping maybe or maybe like using like
guns or something
jumping
[Laughter]
it's true
well
i'd say both those things can be
dangerous if you aren't prepared
to do the task at hand
yes honestly though
jumping would be my greater concern
personally
yes
wise words
a true
person in his natural
time you are that's me
certainly not here to disrupt the
timeline
[Laughter]
oh certainly not certainly not sorry
sam yes
would you call yourself
more of a
competitor in your timeline
or a person
of leadership
if you had to choose
[Music]
competitor
always trying to get
the upper edge
on my competition
yeah all right
yeah
sweet i'm sorry i accidentally paused
the clock
here we go um i think it's been paused
for a while it's okay it's okay this
game's almost over
i sense the disruption on the timeline
there's a disruption on the timeline
someone is here to alter the course of
history and we have to stop it
all right um
you have some great questions and
answers jordan
jay you have some great questions and
answers as well yeah
um um
suspicious of nick um anyway so
yeah
jake
yeah that's me
hey we've been here in this position
before
um
now would you say
if this location
are
you
looking at the environment
at this location
would you say
there's more
is there more
paperwork
or is there more number crunching
if you look at this environment
the
answer to that question
lies within
the
there there it is once said that there
are two lions in in in a person's soul
[Music]
and the lions are fighting
and the lion who wins
is the lion you feed
huh
okay cool
sweet
now let me ask
let me ask
nick one more question
before we sure
vote him out
before we kick him off the timeline
nick it was it is once said that
iron
sharpens iron
was it but the mind
is mightier
than the sharpest sword
would you agree
no
interesting okay
i vote for nick
nick
timeline coliseum no
yes i can't believe you didn't figure it
out i thought we were still
too obvious
here's one more clue
ninja stars
damn it all right no it wasn't shaolin
it was ninja academy oh ninja academy oh
i didn't even see that one there's so
many of you i thought sam was gonna vote
for me for a second i'm like trying to
like just scream you look at my list no
you were all like wise you're all wise
and [ __ ] it was great
ninja academy i should have known i
shouldn't have yeah she should have
known it was the damn ninjas
[Laughter]
the space one probably the boobs we
still never did that
we'll never find out we'll never find
out
all right well
are we done here
i guess so
yeah i was a spy a lot this time man
yeah sorry yeah you were i wasn't the
spy oh i wasn't spy once and i fooled
you all
um okay well
let's play uh another game in the future
but maybe not on the next podcast
because i feel like half the commenters
in this one are gonna say hey
stop playing games this is this podcast
used to be good there's no games two
weeks ago
used to be good like two weeks ago
when you guys actually talked about
stuff instead of
it's been a slow couple weeks okay
i want the hot takes
i want the hot takes on the stuff that's
happening
[Laughter]
and the cold ones too
i want the hot takes
and i want the futuristics
oh yeah
thanks for listening to the quarter cast
everybody
until next time i'll see you on the next
one
peace